we're up against people that want to
allow criminals into our society this
idea of reducing bed space is something
new it is even more extreme than the
Green Deal the big problem here is this
has become pretty much an ego
negotiation some House Democrats are
risking a second partial government
shutdown by calling for this absurd
last-minute poison pill I think we're
going to end up with something that
deals with
detention beds with barriers with
technology with the challenges we have
on the southern border the government
shutdown is technically still on the
table
well the negotiations are continuing
right now at this hour up on Capitol
Hill but there's new wrinkle about
detention beds not letting the Trump
administration have too many of them so
that more families are not held in these
facilities this is what the House
Majority Leader said about that today
clearly if we have people who are
committing crimes putting in danger
either people or property they ought to
be taken off the streets and frankly
incarcerated are held but we're talking
about beds sufficient not to deal with
criminals which is what the case is now
but dealing with people who are working
paying taxes in our community so much
for things looking good president Trump
saying the Democrats do not want us to
detain or send back criminal aliens this
is a brand new demand crazy the
president obviously held heading to our
past so for big event also talking to
Laura Ingraham tonight at 10:00 p.m.
let's bring in our panel Katie Pavlich
newest editor at townhall comm moralize
in the national political correspondent
of National Public Radio and Washington
Post columnist mark teasing apologize
for the voice I thought I could get past
the cold it just wasn't going away mark
it seems like this turns the tide that
it sounded like there was progress being
made yep the Democrats are moving the
goalposts so if you remember during the
whole sequester there when there a key
talking point is we're just against a
wall but we're for border security we're
for enforcement were for all of this
stuff and now all of a sudden they're
threatening a government shutdown
over border bevor over detention beds
it's ridiculous look the the it's clear
that they're not serious about
compromise they're not serious about
reaching a bipartisan deal but the
problem is a shutdown isn't the answer
because they're not afraid of a shutdown
there's no appetite for it among the
Republican caucus the Trump needs to do
something different to shift this debate
and to get his leverage back I think the
way to do that is to threaten use the
threat of a sequester not a shutdown to
get the Democrats to give him his border
money so in December 10 months from now
the the 2011 Obama budget caps kick in
in 2011 and that means that if Congress
doesn't act and the president doesn't
sign something into law 55 billion
dollars in domestic spending gets cut
which our Democratic priorities do
Democrats really want to lose fifty five
billion dollars in domestic spending and
it's just to deny Donald Trump 5.7
billion dollars for his border well I
don't think so
so Trump needs to get a continuing
resolution which the Democrats can't say
no to that just continue spending at the
current levels until the end of the year
and then say I'm not going to do a deal
on the on the sequester that doesn't
include 5.7 billion dollars from my
budget well not to be cliche but more
are Democrats really willing to die on
this wall I would be mystified if they
were they were doing pretty well they
kind of had the President on the ropes
he agreed to their terms to end the
first shutdown he wasn't going to get
the 5.7 billion dollars for the wall and
they were fine with that
just like that when when when the debate
is about the wall and the wall only
Democrats win when the debate is about
border security then the president wins
and I'm mystified by this detention beds
thing I know that they don't like the
ice policies but I don't even know why
minimizing the number of beds would it
would change those policies so I think
either this is a momentary snag right
before everything comes together at the
very last minute like it often does in
Congress or we're heading for another CR
I think your idea is really smart
continuing resolution continuing
resolution either just to give the
negotiators a little more time or if
they go through the end of the year
that means that Trump is pointing a much
longer game Katie at the same time you
have Alexander Acacio Cortez others
saying that I shouldn't be funded at all
it's in the backdrop of this negotiation
on the left side of the Democratic Party
so what's happening but it's also in
extremely bad faith because the reason
why there are not enough detention beds
is because Democrats are rejecting it so
let's look at how we got here last year
there were a number of reports showing
that the humanitarian situation inside
these detention centers was not good
there was overcrowding that were not
enough beds so the White House sent a
letter to Capitol Hill during the
government shutdown in January and
offered five billion dollars almost as
much as the wall to fund 52,000 ice
detention beds to expand the
humanitarian situation there to make
sure that more people were held humanely
and now here we are at Democrats at the
last minute saying we're going to put a
cap on the number of jannat of
humanitarian beds that you can have and
by the way that means that you can
release criminal aliens and illegal
aliens into society and I you have to
look at the language here because as
Mark said Democrats been saying we're
for border security were not for open
borders and yet they're proving
President Ron's point by saying there's
an overcrowding crisis at the border and
at the same time they're admitting that
look we have a problem and we don't have
anything any way to deal with it other
than just limiting it one more thing we
have Democrats saying that illegal
immigrants aren't those immigrants who
are here working and they're law-abiding
paying their taxes and therefore they
shouldn't be held at all that is the
definition of open borders when you
don't want them to be held at all for
coming into the country without
permission which is a federal crime it
is a interesting turn on the
negotiations at the same time the 9th
Circuit Court of Appeals has ruled that
the administration can continue building
this wall in San Diego and also on the
table the national emergency possibility
take a listen to the chief staff that's
absolutely on the table and it's not a
precedent okay this is the law the law
as it exists today I think we've had 58
declaration of national emergencies
since the national emergency act was
passed in the 1970s he would prefer
legislation because it's the right way
to go and it's the proper way to spend
money in this country but if that
doesn't happen the president perceives
his number-one priority is national
security
he will then look at the national
emergencies act as a way to do his job
so could make a down that road tonight
in Malpass oh yeah I think I think that
would be a big mistake because first of
all his own party will rebel against
that because conservatives are worried
that a liberal president maybe someone
from the Acacio cortes wing of the party
is gonna use a national emergency to bid
to do the green New Deal so you don't
want to set the precedent that you can
use a national emergency for something
that's not an actual emergency like the
trainer's don't let that the way to go
is by doing this continuing resolution
because what you think about what a
continuing resolution for ten months
does first it's a defeat for the
Democrats because Nancy Pelosi now has
to abide by the Paul Ryan love spending
levels for an entire year so they just
won the majority their seating the power
of the purse back to the Republicans
number one number two it gives Trump 1.3
billion dollars towards his border wall
Mick Mulvaney is gonna find him some
other funds he's gonna have so he can
start building it now and then in
December he gets the leverage back
because he can hold hostage this 55
billion dollars in spending they want in
exchange for the 5.7 and they're gonna
cave because there's no shutdown it's
just an automatic spending cut but
worked in the White House but Steny
Hoyer says today they don't want to do a
CR they're not gonna do a Sierra well
what are they gonna do right
I see the government shutdown yeah well
they are not gonna no supers tried that
last year now it came to three days they
just want Republicans to shut down the
government that's it they do not want to
be blamed for a shutdown shutdown was
not as bad for President Trump as most
the people in the media made it seem the
economy actually did well there wasn't
this dire straits that everyone was
claiming there's going to unless you
weren't getting a check correct but all
those people got back pay eventually and
that's different than a lot of people in
the Midwest who lost their jobs
overnight in the financial crisis and
didn't get back pay for their jobs so
the point is that yes a government
shutdown is not a good thing but it was
overblown by a large portion when it
came to the negative effects for
President Trump when you look at the
polling and the data economic data
behind it when we came out
yeah yes so does the bed thing go away
did they figure this out that the the
they have to back off of this if our
else there's gonna be a government
shutdown or he's going to take this
smarter approach yeah I agree I agree I
don't know I don't think Democrats are
willing to negotiate in good faith I
think that they want another shutdown
because they think they have the public
relations on their side so I wouldn't
give them too much credit and putting
that taking that off the table we shall
see next